a report from the united nations is
shining new light on the scale of
mexico's crisis with enforced
disappearances citizens who are
kidnapped and disappear without a trace
usually with the knowledge or collusion
of authorities organized crime has
become a central perpetrator of
disappearance in mexico with varying
degrees of participation occurs or
omission
by public servants
states parties are directly responsible
for enforced appearances committed by
public officials but may also be
accountable for his appearances
committed by criminal organizations
[Applause]
over the past two decades disappearances
in mexico have grown exponentially
perhaps no case is more emblematic than
that of 43 students from the ayotzinapa
teachers college in guerrero state in
2014. the incident sparked one of the
largest protest campaigns in mexico in
recent memory
and now the current government says
video evidence presented this year
leaves little doubt that mexican
security forces were the ones
responsible for the disappearance of the
students it also alleges that public
officials as high up as former mexican
president enrique pena nieto knew about
the cover-up to the crime
manuel vasquez-arellano who escaped the
night his classmates were kidnapped is
now a congressman in mexico and says the
problem of enforced disappearances
across the country has only worsened
it is a very big problem which is not
going to be solved in a few years not
even by a few people just like in
colombia just like in other countries
where there have been forced
disappearances on mass or in large
numbers
several presidential administrations in
mexico have attempted to curb violence
and reduce the number of disappeared
people in the country through a
militarized approach
un observers however say this strategy
has failed
the focus on militarization of public
security must be abandoned the committee
is concerned with the militarization of
public security
adopted by the state to combat crime as
it has been insufficient and inadequate
in terms of protecting human rights
the report published by the u.n
committee on enforced disappearances has
also highlighted concerns over
disappearances of human rights workers
migrants and journalists
the u.n has called for immediate actions
by the mexican government to end what
they've referred to as absolute impunity
in cases of enforced disappearances and
to establish a national policy of
prevention as the only way to end the
human tragedy manuel rapalo al jazeera
mexico city